so we're going to have a go at this
question very briefly together and
i know because i wandered around the
breakout rooms and so did mrs lee's
several of you uh even though it's been
a while since we've looked at these
questions maybe you've actually been
revising them recently so
big thumbs up from us which is great so
if you looked at this and thought
absolutely wonderful familiar
i'd advise you to go to the canvas page
and when you have a look at the row for
today's lesson alongside the zoom link
you'll also see two links question one
and question two you're looking at
question one right now
you're welcome to have a look at
question two but i would love you to
also still be listening in even if
you're attempting that other question
uh because the way that i set it out or
the method that i use might be a little
bit different
and i'm not saying it's better but it's
always great having extra
tools in your toolbox to have a go at
solving these tricky questions
so for those of you who had some trouble
let's walk through
how we would go about doing this and as
always many ways to
approach this question but here's one
way that seemed pretty intuitive to me
so the first thing to notice is we've
got this inequality right and for me
especially knowing that these two
numbers a and b are both positive
i think to myself well what's the
easiest path to prove this and
if i know that a and b are both positive
i can make some statements about
something being
greater than or equal to 0 which is
another way of saying non-negative right
so i'm going to take that approach of
taking one side of the inequality
getting everything over to one side i
should say and then considering that
object so here's the way i
set things out i said let's consider
what happens if we take everything onto
the left hand side so that would be
minus two thirds i'm just considering
this whole
algebraic expression there's no
inequalities i'm going to introduce the
inequality once i can make some
statements that are reasonable
about this okay so in order to
start to bring things together i'm going
to literally bring things together by
combining these three fractions
into one so you might be able to see how
this is
not too difficult to do if for instance
you just had a look at those first two
fractions you say okay
i can get that denominator of a b no
trouble there
and then if i multiply through by um
three i can get everything
combined so i'm going to write it like
so three lots of this
and then i'll have a b lots of this so
you can see me doing that sort of
it's not cross multiplication but you
get the idea it's quite similar
okay now from here um what do you do
next
and uh for me when i was having a go at
this question this was the first
non-intuitive step because i thought to
myself yeah i can expand that i can
write 3a
plus 3b minus 2ab but then at least in
my brain
it is not immediately apparent where to
go next and so i pause
and i think how can i actually use the
information provided to me in the
question
to help me and you'll notice that not
only did we get given this result we had
to prove
not only did we get told that a and b
are both positive
but we also get this piece of
information here
that the sum of a and b is 6. how do i
use that um there's a couple of
different ways we could do it right
for instance i could say look there's an
a plus b right there
i could substitute that for 6 because
that's equal
right so then you get 18 minus 2 a b
is that helpful to write 18 minus 2
a b on the numerator whilst i have a 3
a b on the denominator now
i'm about to show you why this is
actually a dead end but it's really
important that you think through
why it's a dead end this is the big
problem with reading other people's
solutions as you're going through and
revising and
you do a past paper and you're like oh i
don't know how to do this one so you
look at the solution
and then you just read it and it is
presented in a like
a direct form as if like someone was
solving a jigsaw puzzle
and they put down the first piece first
and then they just went in a row and
just
put down every piece in order you can't
actually solve a jigsaw puzzle
like that you have to kind of piece
things together put some together that
don't quite fit and then make your way
out of that once you make an error how
can we know
that this particular way of writing it
whilst true
isn't particularly helpful okay so
here's my first question to you and i'd
love to post this in the chat
we'll go with an easy thing first have a
look at the denominator of this fraction
down here given what we know about a
and b what can you tell me about the
denominator
of this fraction what what qualities or
what attributes does it have
which are useful to me can anyone go
ahead and suggest
any ideas
okay fantastic yes so got a few entries
in there and be brave um thank you to
people who direct messaged me but you
can you can throw it out there we've got
we're very happy to throw out all these
ideas so i've got people saying it's
positive
parhan's gone even more detailed and
said it's positive and it's
it's less than 27 okay and you can think
about
how you know that because you've got
this this sort of
lock on how big a plus b are together
now for me the magnitude is useful but
i'm more interested in the fact that
it's positive right because
i've got this division from the
numerator to the denominator if the
denominator is positive
then it's enough for me to prove the is
also positive
positive divided by positive i don't
care how big it is i just care that it's
going to be greater than or equal to 0.
so that would be really cool right so i
can say oh nice i know that about the
denominator
when you have a look at the numerator
it's not quite so obvious right because
you've actually got this subtraction
going on so even though you could still
argue some
ways through this because you know some
things about its magnitude i think
there's another more helpful direction
or a more obvious direction you could go
in to show the solution or show the
proof for this
that this expression here is indeed
going to be greater than or equal to
zero
here's how i'm going to do it you
remember i said we can
we can substitute this for six we can
take an a plus b out and put a 6 in its
place
well if i can take an a plus b out and
put a 6 in its place
it stands to reason that i can also do
the reverse if i see
6 anywhere i can replace that with an a
plus b
now i don't see any sixes yet but it's
not hard to introduce a six
in there for instance if i multiply the
whole thing
by two over two right
it's just an equivalent fraction so if i
wrote this 6
times a plus b on the numerator minus 4
a b on the denominator and then we're
still divided by
um 6 a b down here because i multiplied
that by 2 as well okay
now why is this useful to me and the
answer is in the same way that i looked
at this and i saw i could swap it
for a 6 i can look at this 6 and i can
swap it for an a
plus b this is useful because i'm trying
to show these things positive
right and one of the things you might
remember from inequality proofs is that
squares at least in the domain of real
numbers in the field of real numbers
squares are phenomenally useful to do
that so you can see
i'm about to introduce an a plus b
all squared because there's the 6. you
can see uh
where i got that from that's where that
transition was made that substitution
and then you can see over here i have
this minus four a
b and from here i think most of you are
probably
okay to carry on right the denominator
is still positive
i didn't change its sign i just changed
its magnitude by multiplying by two
up on the numerator you've got a squared
plus two a b
plus b squared and combined with this uh
minus four a b on the numerator you're
going to be able to turn this into a
perfect square
right it'll be a squared minus two a b
plus b squared which you can factorize
so that's going to be
a minus b or squared
once you collect like terms
with these so i'll leave that for you to
write up
and at this point um i'm so confident
that you know what to do from here i'm
not even going to write the rest but i
will talk you through it okay
i've got a denominator that we already
established as positive
because a and b are both positive so the
product of two positive numbers is
positive
you've got this thing up here and
because you can see by the way
one of the ways that i knew this was
dealing with real numbers and not with
complex numbers because you're like mr
wu
there's good squared we know things that
square and a negative and the way you
knew that is because of this
restriction here it's a bit sneaky it's
kind of implicit right
but to be greater than zero is a
statement you can only make of
one-dimensional numbers
does that make sense you can't say
greater or lesser than with complex
numbers because you're like
greater or less than in which dimension
are we talking about the real or the
imaginary
as soon as you say something is greater
than zero you have
locked it into being a one dimensional
number which is to say a real number so
this implies that a and b
are real so on the basis of that no
matter what
a and b you choose you can you can
square them and get a positive number
so positive divided by a positive what
that's going to give to you is remember
you've got this on the left hand side
right so having made the argument for
why this has to be greater than or equal
to zero
um you can see i'm sort of linking these
different uh terms along so that's going
to give me
this left hand side that i considered if
it's equal to something that's greater
than or equal to zero
it is also itself greater than or equal
to 0. so from there
i can just write the result that i was
after 1 on a
plus 1 and b is greater than 2 3
as required so the only thing that i
would just point out
is to remember that this line right here
this requires that justification around
the denominator being
positive and y and the numerator being
positive and
y okay so i hope you enjoyed that and it
made sense to you and that you were
actually
able to notice what was tricky about
this you have to kind of see
um what what you're gonna do with this
strange a plus b equals six and what's
what's useful and what's not so useful